Now let's see another type of predictor that combines prediction decisions which
is called a hierarchical predictor. It is similar to the tournament predictor,
but the tournament predictor typically is trying to combined two
good predictors. One is good for some branches, the other for others.
The hierarchical predictor is trying to combined a good predictor with an okay
predictor. Here you're basically doing two good predictions for every branch.
Just to use one of them. And each of the good predictors costs you a lot, for
each entry. Here the idea is you that you have a very good predictor that costs
you a lot for it's entry. But you don't want to be using the good predictor for
branches that are very easy to predict anyway. So the idea is that for
those branches, you want to use the okay predictor. And
use the good predictor entries, which are very expensive, only for
branches that really need that good predictor. So in the tournament predictor,
you will update both predictors on each decision so
that they can both stay current with what's going on. And thus,
they both try to do their best on each branch decision. But in
the hierarchical predictor, you might update the OK predictor on each decision.
But you update the good predictor, only the OK predictor did not work well for
that branch. The idea here is to not use the entries of
the good predictor if the OK one is doing fine. On this branch so really what
that means is we can have very expensive entries in the good predictor. And
we have relatively few entries because most of the branches will be handled just
fine with the OK predictor. If we try to compare the tournament predictor with
the hierarchical predictor the hierarchical one usually wins. Because it
turns out that there are many many branches. That can be predicted just fine
using something like just a simple two bit counter. On the other hand, there
are some branches that really require a very strong predictor to predict them.
In a tournament predictor, each of the predictors is a balance between cost and
accuracy. In this predictor, you can build a very expensive predictor with
very few entries. And an OK predictor, it has a lot of branches. So
those branches can handle like this, which leaves the rest of the resources for
the good predictor. And that means it can have extremely long histories or
be a very, very fancy predictor. You can even have a hierarchy or
for that matter an tournament with more than, just two predictors.